avec nous le commissaire divisionnaire
honoraire maurice signolet vous
remercier d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france tout d'abord votre réaction
puisque le projet de loi vient d'être
adopté en première lecture
oui bah c'est une réaction un peu de
désarroi quand même vous savez que un
certain nombre de policiers retraités
libérés de leur devoir de réserve ont
décidé de décrire l'ensemble des
parlementaires justement pour dire à
quel point on était opposé à cette forme
de réformes vous avez parlé en dernier
en dernier lieu dans votre votre
reportage de la présence de l'avocat
lors des perquisitions
on sent très bien que c'est quelque
chose qui va rendre encore plus
difficile le travail des policiers si
vous voulez depuis on se rend compte
qu'il ya une corrélation évidente entre
une cascade de réformes depuis 20 25 ans
concernant le code pénal concernant le
code de procédure pénale et la montée de
la violence la montée de la délinquance
là le refus de toute autorité on voit
bien qu'à une corrélation très nette
on a l'impression qu'une nouvelle fois
un nouvel à nouveau par va être franchie
en accordant encore plus de deux
possibilités à la défense au détriment
des forces de l'ordre
quelque part on est on est
extraordinairement sidéré de voir que
depuis des décennies le politique
n'arrête pas de parler de sécurité est
en réalité dans les apps dans
l'élaboration des diverses les diverses
lois et désarment les policiers donc il
ya un espèce de cris de colère beaucoup
de policiers retraités on sait notre
légitimité c'est les 40 années qu'on a
passées dans la police donc on a vu
cette évolution cette fois on parle et
donc on a décidé d'adresser un courrier
à l'adresse de tous les parlementaires
faites attention vous êtes le signataire
justement de cette lettre ouverte dont
vous parlez aux parlementaires qui
s'attaque à cette réforme et vos mots
sous forges du site et quelques extraits
chacun d'entre vous sera comptable de
l'issue de ces propositions a en iv mais
diable chaos sociétal génocidaire se
profile tandis qu'une élite s'accommode
de cette guerre
elle ne subit pas elle est mauvaise à ce
point cette réforme selon vous c'est une
suite logique si vous voulez en quelque
part on dénonce quelque chose de
fondamental on a abandonné totalement la
procédure à kizito rial au profit d'une
procédure accusatoire de qui existe de
longue date dans les pays anglo saxons
mais qui n'est pas qui ne correspond pas
à la culture policière française qui ne
correspond pas à la culture française
on a énormément de mal si vous voulez on
ne peut pas s'empêcher de faire le coach
me dit tout à l'heure
le corollaire entre cette cascade de
davantage donné on de donner à la
défense de neo délinquante par rapport
aux forces de l'ordre
et aujourd'hui par ruissellement par
effet papillon dans l'oralité
vous avez tout ce qui se passe dans nos
banlieues aujourd'hui qui fait que
l'autorité policière n'a plus aucun sens
selon vous qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
changer dans cette réforme quels sont
les principaux qu'il faudrait revoir
alors tout d'abord on à moi j'étais que
surya m'ont surpris de voir que à
l'occasion de cette manifestation de
près trente cinq mille policiers
il ya eu des invectives à l'égard de la
justice justice police ont c'est le même
combat
la police n'est que le bras armé de la
justice la justice elle même depuis
depuis quelques décennies a subi
également c'est vague de réformes ces
vagues de réforme du code pénal le code
de procédure pénale qui enfin conflit un
petit peu tout le monde
alors la difficulté c'est que on a
presque envie de dire je pense que c'est
platon qui disait à prendre c'est se
souvenir de ce qu'on est obligé
peut-être qu'il faudrait se tourner j'ai
pas de nostalgie mais je voudrais
peut-être que l'on se tourne vers ce
qu'il fonctionnait auparavant et qui
faisaient que une justice était vraiment
rendu la sécurité et la sûreté des
français étaient présentes la justice
manque d'autorité aujourd'hui selon vous
oui elle se retrouve dans la même
situation que nous si vous voulez il ya
eu toute une cascade de loi comprenant
pas le juger des libertés de la
détention
on a commencé à rogner de plus en plus
le rôle de juge d'instruction qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui aussi bien la police que
la justice se retrouve près prise en
étau police et justice on est pris en
étau dans une espèce de procédures
infernale
dont on ne sort pas et qui
pédagogiquement on en termes
d'exemplarité est un très mauvais signal
adressé à l'ensemble de la population
parce que justement l'autorité de la
justice l'autorité policière les
policiers étaient des fonctionnaires
d'autorité est aujourd'hui totalement
mise à mal on voit très bien ce qui se
passe dans ces banlieues tous les jours
tout le monde le dénonce la presse les
médias s'en font l'écho tous les jours
mais en vain contre sabarat que c'est
exactement inverse
paske intellectuellement on est rentré
dans un espèce de cycle un peu infernal
qui fait qu on ne veut plus voir les
réalités en quelque sorte comme je le
dis dans comme je le dis dans ma lettre
on voit ce que l'on croit et on ne croit
pas ce que l'on voit c'est toute la
différence
donc on veut un peu éclairé quelque part
les parlementaires en leur disons
attention à cette nouvelle démarche qui
risque d'être lourde de conséquences une
fois de plus est ce que vous pensez que
ce gouvernement s'est définitivement mis
la police à dos où on sait que l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner mais aussi des difficultés avec
les policiers il ya eu des maladresses
diverses et variées mais vous savez là
la police est toujours quelque part en
otage
je crois que l'une des grandes
responsabilités du gouvernement présent
de gouvernement sous la présidence de
monsieur mâcon c'était l'épisode des
gilets jaunes qui a fait quelque part un
mal terrible à l'institution policière
puisque en fin de compte on s'est
retrouvés un instrument politique de
d'une situation qu'ils appelaient une
réponse politique et certainement pas
une réponse policière
et quelque part on le voit bien un an
lorsqu'il nous arrive de discuter avec
les gens on voit bien qu'un fossé s'est
creusé on voit bien que quelque chose
s'est cassé mais quelque part on en
n'était pas responsable
merci beaucoup maurice signolet d'avoir
répondu à ces questions je rappelle que
vous êtes commissaire divisionnaire
honoraire merci à vous